each year Microsoft Research hosts
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
okay we're honored today to have Joel
Robertson founder and CEO of Robertson
technologies joel is a scientist and and
what I seen his bio social entrepreneur
it's a nice phrase he's developed quite
a few health care programs using I'm
computing as its foundation Robertson
technologies is dedicated to making
having impact on healthcare around the
world and it's a guess it's a network of
nonprofit and for-profit organizations
with a kind of a global perspective joel
is the also the visionary behind next
opinion written in x opinion healthcare
platform that is based on probabilistic
methods for doing diagnosis and
recommendation that application over the
years has been known as an application
built on Microsoft Technology it's been
featured in a variety of ways and it it
earned the Robertson of 2000 for
Computerworld honors award nomination
and I always liked bios that in like
this I think it's really nice dr.
Robertson founded his organization on
the principles of compassion respect and
hope three nights squared so today Joe
will talk a bit about next opinion a
novel integrated and predictive solution
for global health care delivery
thanks Eric the first thing that I'll do
is apologize because when you take an
hour and a half and you have to talk
about vision you have to talk about
science and you have to talk about
applications you can't go deep into all
of them and so for those of you who want
more information more than willing to
share with you so we're going to try to
do that in an hour and a half talk about
all of those various aspects of next
opinion so that you can see this is a
product that has gone from R&D and
definitely we usually say you can see
David heck erman all over it david has
been actively involved from the
beginning in helping us to design the
mathematics which also go back to to
Eric Horowitz and David's philosophies
that have come into this application and
it's very definitely have as a Microsoft
stamp on it because of that aspect of
those guys in their research and
thinking they're the minds behind it we
kind of put it into making it at work in
the real world Robertson technologies is
a we refer to it as a Robin Hood theory
of Medicine you make money where there's
money and you give it to the poor and so
we have profits and nonprofits 501 c 3
public charities we work with various
organizations such as the Bill and
Melinda Gates Foundation Intel world
ahead johnson & johnson project unite a
lot of those nonprofits as well as in
the profit world you're going to see
this fall along try two UPG with the one
app will be on the one app platform most
notably towards South Africa India so
that the whole theory is how can we make
a significant difference in world
medicine is what we look at and it comes
through partnering and partnering with
with people such as Microsoft in order
to be able to deliver a solution there
is all of us when you look at it in in
the world of the developed country there
is an ethical respond
ability for us to care for the poor in
2002 is when you know I was kind of
setting there and had a successful
publishing career and behavioral
medicine arian began to look at you know
what about the rest of the world and
I've done enough international traveling
to say we do have a responsibility for
us to to look at the poor around the
world and especially if the solution
lies within technology which we do
believe at looking at how can we get
there in indy alone there's 512 million
who will never see a physician and i'll
say very simply should everyone see a
physician yes but the reality is it
can't happen so how can you take
medicine safe with clinical supervision
to the poor without having quacks
delivering the care but having good
solid medicine and getting good metrics
out of it the only way you can do it is
through technology and so that was our
solution that's what we looked at and we
said we have to have it innovative one
of the most important things about a
solution for the porters it has to be
more sophisticated than a solution for
the wealthy when you take people who
don't know enough to ask the question
you have to be smart enough to ask the
question that they don't know to ask so
that was one of our challenges to say
how do you get software that's that
smart that it can get into people who
are untrained and yet get a right answer
so in 2002 we started next opinion and
we started it in a non-profit
environment for two reasons another guy
and I invested in it and we didn't know
if we could do it in fact we had doubts
we at least wanted a tax write-off but
we had three questions you know could we
do it could technology do it and does
anyone want it and so we did those three
questions in the nonprofit and when he
came up with the answer to that solution
then we kind of moved into an area that
said let's add the profit to be able to
move on so it could it be done one of
the things that was very important is
there had been a lot of programs out
there qmr a lot of programs that have
been out there in the area of clinical
decision support and things about nature
but one of the first things that we had
to do is we said is there the ability to
be able to be smart enough again if you
don't know a question
to be able to get to the answer let me
use an example of how this works and
i'll give you a big picture how it works
and we'll take it from there let's say
you're 19 year old female it's februari
you're in vonnegan opoly andhra pradesh
india and you have a cough and you have
a health worker that that's all they
know this software has to be smart
enough to know what are the most likely
diseases at that time of the month in
that location they're going to show up
with a cough and begin to ask the
question to differentiate between the
top diseases then it has to give you a
confidence level that you have that
disease and then if it's a disease one
you're able to treat because you've been
permitted to treat it such as malaria
may be able to be treated by a rural
health worker and you have a confidence
level then you get a green light to move
to the treatment and that treatment
might be chloroquine next what's
important is a few days later you ask
the person are they taking their
medication and not are they getting
better but as the other chills better
are the intermittent fevers because
you're looking at the symptoms so you
have to have a findings based
diagnostics then you have to have a
follow-up based reverse thinking asking
findings as whether they're clearing up
that's the general just of what this is
all about so we found that we needed
multiple diagnostic engines if we
started just with Bayes for example
which is probabilistic you'd run down a
lot of bunny trails we also found that
there wasn't a database that existed to
support that kind of data there's
millions and millions of relationships
that have to be in their relationships
that are regionalized what is what has
exists in the u.s. is not at all
relevant to something that might exist
in south africa or Rwanda is might be
very different than the mountains of
uttaranchal and in india so you really
had to have a database and there wasn't
anything there so we said well I guess
we have to develop it and that was fun
when we began to test that we tested it
through a lot of different dynamics and
it's been well tested it's in the
commercialization phase and I think bill
crowns here director worldwide health in
a recent
the program that i did with him said the
result of this work next opinion is one
of the most significant accurate
responsive and intuitive diagnostic
programs I've seen and that's pretty
much what we get could technology
supported in 2004 Steve Ballmer said
that we cut our costs by ninety percent
are developed time by fifty-eight
percent and we need like thirty five to
forty percent as much code so better
solutions delivered quickly more
maintainable supportable in a very very
mission-critical environment that is
essentially what we see ourselves our
space is what Steve Ballmer had talked
about that's what we do best we partner
with people that do other stuff better
because the solution on such a vast
problem has to be a working on
cooperation between various
organizations good technology we had
lots of questions you know what can you
do there's connectivity issues and you
know you've got all kinds of mobile
platforms and how do you get data in on
a mobile platform and how do you make it
be able to integrate all the way up
through a hospital HIAS system all
communicate together and so what we
decided is that we've developed what's
called a platform it's a database
management platform multiple ways of
getting data and multiple ways of
getting data out all using an integrated
system needs to be modular modular for
example a level one worker is somebody
who doesn't know much so why ask them
the same question you're going to ask a
specialist physician so modular in that
when you publish that out to a phone
only the questions that they can ask our
ask of them for a usability issue and if
they don't have labs don't ask them
about labs but when they get up into a
PhD a primary health center and they may
have the availability of labs what labs
are available and what can we put the
data in to enhance the diagnostics and
more importantly could we tell them what
would be important to help them
differentiate the diagnosis so we really
had to have a multiple platform and I
think the biggest challenge would has to
be agnostic there are so many databases
out there that we have to be able to
read to pull from and write back to
those platforms because those databases
if we're going to do global medicine
people already have various you know
because strong and openmrs we've got a
lot of different systems but if we want
to look at global medicine we have to be
able to agnostic alee look and be able
to jump into the health faults jump into
the the open em our asses in many
different areas and to be able to read
in and out question would anyone want it
what happened when we finished our tests
and we went through various tests around
the world 90 different test sites in 14
different countries and basically it
came back in our conclusion at this
particular point isn't does anyone want
it but how in the world do we partner
with people to support the enthusiasm of
what has been developed one of the
examples that we talk about does it work
for them when we recently just got an
article where the physician had
diagnosed in a a rural village in in
India that the I mean the multi purpose
health worker to diagnose and
indigestion and they ran it through the
the next opinion came back and said it
looks like it could be an mi and then
referred the person up and it was an mi
that's an example of the type of stuff
that that patient would not have been
treated because there was not the
information available so we have
thousands of ongoing clinical encounters
so one of the questions comes up how did
we do it and so because we're here with
Microsoft Research we want to talk a
little bit about what's the the the
mathematics logic behind it as well as
our vision for the use of it so the
first thing is we had to develop an
engine and as I said we developed four
engines one bombed and so we ended up
with three that work and they all work
simultaneously in one diagnostics so
it's rather interesting on how we were
able to do that but the key thing is
that needed to mimic clinical reasoning
it needed to think like a doctor and it
needed to be predictive and then the
database had to be modular it had to be
global and it had to be regionalized in
order to do this if you want to do it on
a world basis you have to regionalize
regionalize includes language but
includes terms there are four different
terms for diarrhea in the state of
Andhra Pradesh alone in India so how do
you do that what are the terms that they
refer to because information and/or
Diagnostics out as only as good as
information in and then most importantly
taking complex extremely complex program
needs to be user-friendly
so we started out with bays and I think
that's why you hear terms such as hi
cameran and Horowitz because when you
think Bay's that's what you think of so
we started out with bays and we said I
like this this concept it says Bayes
theorem can then be understood as
specifying how an ideal irrational
person responds to evidence now we're
making an assumption that physicians are
ideal irrational which is a stretch
sometimes but if we use that concept we
say how do we do that so it really comes
back our first thing is saying how do we
take medical facts put them in a
clinically weighted you need to know how
important is that symptom to that
disease and how important is is that
symptom related to that how do we do
that so you have a probability factor
and we went through a lot of discussions
with David we talked about sensitivity
specificity positive predictive value is
negative and we came up with something
that said there is a clinical predictive
value and so what we use and I'll talk
about later is what we call the cpv very
important to clinically predict a value
prevalence data which you also need in
order to run Bay's you're going it's
scattered it's spotty it's slanted you
know you may get data on a hospital in
the US but where's the relevance
elsewhere and its really looking at what
is the clinical presentation probability
and so we use this clinically weighted
prevalence and what it really says is
clinicians agree with it you can rapidly
regionalize it and most importantly at
this particular point in science that
data is subjective until you've got
enough data back to turn it into
empirical and so it needs to be a
learning process that says this is what
we believe to be the clinically weighted
prevalence but in time will validate
that or change it so this is our best
guess that's what you have to look at it
because that's where we're at in this
field sensitivity you know is this a
test is it a symptom is it a sign so we
went into the clinical data descriptive
aspect and we said you know physicians
typically think in terms of I often see
this I rarely see it or you know in our
experience so you have to take this
clinically semantic approach and do what
we called a see
TV which is a clinical predictive value
that really means how much does X evoke
and a suspicion of Y so now you've got
those two terms that we use cpv and cwp
and we developed what's called buckets
and this again we tried to go through
and there is no specific numbers that
exist so what are the buckets that exist
so with a cwp you'd say is that a very
rare is it a rare is it common very
common you can get consensus on that cpv
you can get consensus on this is rare
it's often it's typically associated
with it the strength of using the bucket
is that you got a broad clinical
agreement and you can also regionalize
fairly rapidly you can see these are the
top 10 diseases that we see in rural
medicine globally but here in sub-sahara
Africa would you add some to that bucket
or would you take them away and then the
same thing you can do with findings
these findings are often associated with
these diseases would you add something
to that bucket or take it away the next
thing that was very important is leaks
one of the things that I've I was always
struggled with with clinical decision
support systems is you have to know what
to put in it's almost like you need to
know the answer before you put the data
in and what if we were going to take
data for example an electronic health
record and we want to incorporate all
the data into the Diagnostics everything
that's there your disease to disease
relationships your pre-existing diseases
whether you have a village that has
mosquito-infested malaria diseases or
whether you have bad water or whether
you have previously had an mi all of
that's important in a physician's mind
but they can run make Bay's run on a
bunny trail if I'm putting in that I
have a headache I'm busy and I have a
sore foot there's three facts but two of
them are related and one is not so the
challenge of how do you get irrelevant
data not to mess you up and take you
down a bunny trail if the assumption is
we need to make this work with non
trained individuals who don't know the
answer as to what's relevant and that
includes our consumer
that includes sometimes a physician
who's not specialized because the
disease's specialized and it often
occurs in very rare diseases that are
not seen very frequently the physician
may be the one who says I don't know
enough to ask that question in order to
do that we had to create what's called a
multiple engine and the first thing when
you enter in data in this particular
system is it uses a rules-based engine
on templates what it is is we are
gathering up and building prior
probabilities because at that particular
point by asking questions directly to
get prior probabilities prior to Bay's
kicking in you have taken related
symptoms and build up enough that Bay's
can then start in a prediction but if
you did not do that you'd have a
multiplicity of data and never be able
to get bey's to work so we create a
chief complaint templates that are
related things so if you say cough you
may want to know is there sputum
production you may want to know whether
that's cardiovascular oriented or you
want to know you know whether it's it's
a respiratory related so you ask a few
questions to get the related
probabilities together and then let
Bay's kick in in addition to that base
is a great pas probabilistic engine but
sometimes there are possible diseases
that Bay's will miss so I ran
simultaneously in a current spaced
engine so that when you see our software
it'll say this is what's probably in
existence but you can kick in and say
what is possible and then Bay's can take
a possible disease and make it into a
probable disease with the specific
findings so you can go to possible click
on it and then enter in the findings
that make it into a probable disease so
that was the creative thing so we had to
do is we had to create a suggestions we
call it one more question it needs to
look through and when you get to a
certain point in Bay's that you've got
five or in our case we use 10 top
diseases let's ask the questions of you
that will differentiate those top 10
diseases
because you may not know enough to ask
it so we'll ask that in clinical uses
rather fascinating because you could put
a finding in let's say you could put a
result of a cat scan in and see what it
changing your probability before you
spent the money on the cat scan so as
you can see there's a lot of uses for
this sort of thing let me describe
something as you go through i want you
to connect this we feel what we built is
a combustion engine that can be used in
a weedwacker or it can be used in a
Ferrari and so the application of where
it is used is varied upon the the user
where they're looking at our they're
looking at it from a health care cost
containment predictive are you looking
at it diagnostic are you looking at a
rural health in order to be able to do
that so we developed this platform this
is a way that we did some some early
engine testing where we just would put
in probabilities and we look at diseases
and we put it in front of expert
witnesses and we would expert witnesses
expert panels and we put it in front of
run use cases that that may be in
literature or something that nature to
see if we were on the right track the
database then became rather interesting
because now you're talking about when
you when you add lab and you add imaging
and you add findings and you add various
locations an extraordinarily complex
database so when you look at the data
you can start out you can say in general
textbooks I can find some relations and
if you look at most of the clinical
decision support you'll be able to see
them you know connect in with you know
griffiths five-minute clinical diagnosis
things like that it's nothing more than
these symptoms file fall with this
there's no prevalence there's no
sensitivity but there's a relationship
and then the next thing that you do is
you have to go through and you after
author certain specialty text and in our
particular case because we felt that we
were on the road of building something
rather interesting every single finding
has to be documented of where that
finding came from and what piece of
literature and you have to have a
standard on what literature is
legitimate and what is not so all of
that comes with our what we call our
our content management team so then you
go general then the next level you go
specialty text and then the next thing
you have to do is go to literature
review and there's where you have some
real standards of saying what is
legitimate information what is a
legitimate study and then the criteria
before that data can be considered a
positive relational and what we call
published data then we go through
medical expert reviews and these reviews
what we did was originally on a global
aspect just what are the disease
relationships what are the finding
relationships that goes through these
these internal specialists and then you
go next to the international so let's
say that there are approximately 850
diseases that you may look at outside of
psychiatric and orthopedics and so you
look at that and then there are for
example 212 diseases that are seen
frequently in rural medicine and so you
have a global what we call rural
medicine diseases of 212 then you might
go to India and take that specialist and
they'll say these are the 2 12 within
India and then you might go to Africa
and say these are the ones that fall
within there and add and subtract to it
so you're taking this data and not only
on the relationship that exists with the
original diagnosis but the relationship
it exists within that region so we
developed in what we call the the next
opinion knowledge management platform in
early on we met with the team from
Microsoft from content management and
some technology people to describe our
content because we said can we buy a
content management system in the
conclusion back in 2004-5 i believe it
was was there isn't anything that exists
that can do this so we had to build it
on her own and with a lot of again
support from Microsoft so we developed
these things that are called rapid
regionalization we have a finding named
a regionalized named a disease name and
then various ways that we can very
quickly go in and regionalize a disease
after we got the clinical decision
support and we began to do some studies
on the accuracy and efficiency in
you know the quality the Diagnostics we
found that there are a couple of things
that were very important one of them is
that we found that you know a clinical
decision support without a certain
infrastructure and electronic health
record storage data the ability to do
metric silent was somewhat there wasn't
a purpose for it it was great technology
but as Eric and I were talking prior
technology putting it in to the rubber
meets the road of making it work we
found that we required that every
encounter their person had has to build
on a health record if you see a person
and for example you see a pregnant woman
and you put her in the database and
she's eight months pregnant you have two
people in a database you have a woman
who is pregnant and you have a minus 1
month child who's going to be needing to
be asked was they born alive or not in
in a month so you need to have the data
that says every encounter creates it and
you have to be able to monitor the
metrics of that so we included a sweet
so we kind of look at the platform and
you're going to see when I described the
platform a diagnostic engine an event
engine a search engine but you're also
going to have a electronic health record
and a reporting and metrics that are all
associated in the suite that is a
platform how you access that could be
through for example our Microsoft UPG
one app might be a PC it might be
web-based whatever it is you access this
where it's stored could be proprietary
and we'll talk about some of the
challenges that come in working globally
so next opinion version one the database
took us four years and more than six
million dollars just to put the numbers
in and in if you look at that that's
actually a very very efficient number
for those of you who've been involved in
this field and we did it by using a very
very skilled group of people and because
we are a small company low overhead you
you're very agile and so that was what
we did the next thing we had to do is
look at clinica you
and Microsoft actually sent a team with
us to the Dominican Republic when we
first started and and and this was kind
of the first time I'd gone from the the
theory into the practicality and we'd
take the next opinion and put it in
front of doctors and no one would tell
them how to use it and Microsoft team
would watch and see where they got stuck
what I can tell you today is it takes
less than an hour for a person to really
use this software now there's a lot of
features that will take longer you know
metrics and stuff but it's a very very
user friendly as said we we had become
one of the top five finalists in the
world I in 2004 as the best medical
solutions as nominated through the
computer world awards we've done some
academic and clinical studies I just put
a couple of them there we we did a
improvement of diagnostic performance of
indian general practitioners we found
the general practitioners increase their
diagnostic accuracy between 25 and
forty-one percent as compared to the
specialist physician diagnosis and that
was in GI diseases well we of course ran
it against some of the powerhouse and
we'll show you some of those studies but
we also you ran it with who can use use
it so that you looked at use case of
conacher's use it what Kenosha's do what
are the limits of these people can some
of them only gather data can some of
make diagnostics what are the multi
purpose health workers come in did you
improve not only their data collection
integrity the data did you improve their
diagnostic skills so all of those tests
have been done and will bore you with
those but here's an example for example
side-by-side comparison of some of the
diagnostic programs now I'd like you to
look at the line for we're next opinions
about a ninety four percent and you take
some of these like epocrates and Isabel
and they're around 83 284 but one of the
most important thing is that's if they
put the data in and you have to know the
data to put in if you spell it wrong it
doesn't get in if you don't know what to
enter it doesn't get in so even though
you put all the data in side by side
were more accurate what's more important
is because we ask for data from an end
user
most of those programs will be around
sixty percent accurate where will still
maintain our our ninety ninety percent
or so because we're asking questions
where those aren't and you can put in
multiple symptoms you could put in
safaga and headache in most of them and
get to fax we will not the way that
we've developed it is that's one fact we
did some pilot studies well many pilot
studies Dominican Republic one of the
things that we did is just threw it into
a college student to see if they could
gather information the quote unquote
back was this is easier than falling out
of bed that was very important for us to
be able to say Kim data collection which
is very important because you know in in
global medicine we have to know who
exists you know in getting data in very
easily done in Congo we worked at it
with the with you know various teaching
hospitals and and in in uttaranchal in
various places andhra pradesh done a lot
of the pilot studies initially to see if
we were on looking at the current
features one of the things that i think
is very important is that next opinion
has a personal health record now i'm
going to use the term differently
personal health record than most people
and i come from a behavioral medicine
background and so from that standpoint
I'm going to make a statement that comes
from that background and I say you know
personal health records when you think
of us as consumers where you're getting
data in your typing data in I make the
comments sometime that says you know
that data is probably not going to be
interred unless you have a little bit of
an OCD in you if you have a little bit
of assess of compulsive disorder you're
going to keep your health record because
why am I going to keep my health record
we use the phase i will keep a health
record if i can interact in it if i can
ask it questions you take the technology
of next opinion you could go into your
health record with more technology but
i'm saying the engine does this I could
say can I drink red Bull and it will go
in and say you have hypertension
you're on this antihypertensive it is
not indicated it is contraindicated no
you can't are you looking for energy
this software right now with the
supporting systems can do that that is a
health record to me that's an
interactive personal health record that
is something that will be used
universally because I now have a reason
to have that and interact with that so
we look at it and we say we needed to be
able to access this health record from a
cellular device our first cellular
device of course has come through
Microsoft UPG in the one app and it is
very very cool and that platform what he
can do is is really slick and so that's
something that will sometime around
November be released personal pcs
obviously but it also needs to be able
to be incorporated into the public
health and into the hospital information
systems we have an H is a dashboard that
I'll show you that uses all of this sort
of stuff your health record also has to
have vital data registration and
integration to give you an example of
how simple it is is let's say using the
UPG phone one app if you are data
collecting and you went into a village
the first thing that might ask the rural
health worker is a village questionnaire
and it might be asking questions about
water quality it might be asking
questions about airborne diseases and
that questionnaire is filled out on that
phone one time the next time you go and
you enter in a patient and create a
patient record all that data is entered
into their health record because that's
important in making diagnoses so the
ability to be able to integrate the
ability to be able to go in and say if I
have a mother with a history of diabetes
and I create a son that son has a family
history of diabetes I don't need to
enter that in so that we're looking at
being able to get in so the data entry
is so easy that we're going to get good
data and vital statistics the other
thing important with this clinical
decision support is it needs to be used
with skilled or non skilled user
interfaces we use three different levels
level one is a person who really can
only ask symptoms and only at a limited
basis on a handful of diseases and there
are five major diseases for example to
create a significant number of death
around the world and there are ways to
be able to get a fairly high confidence
level with symptoms that might be a
level-1 level-2 says I have some
rudimentary laboratory and imaging I
might have a chest x-ray and I have a
few labs available and i can ask those
next level questions that might be a
accredited nurse midwife or it might be
a multi purpose health worker or
somebody of that nature and you need to
be able to plug in various devices blood
pressure monitors etc so that you you
take away the training of the individual
and various organizations or companies
have those and then you have level three
which is highly sophisticated I've got a
specialist I've got a lot of information
so each interface and each question has
to be very different every template has
to be different for example with the
lowest level you go through a chief
complaint the next level you might go I
can go to disease and I can start
entering my findings very quickly and
then find out my predictive diagnostic
various ways you can go in when you get
up to the higher levels you need to be
able to customize management and
treatment for each of those levels when
you take a rural health worker and they
can't they're away from a hospital and
they can't have the access to the
medication then you have to give them
various ways of stabilizing disease and
transferring we believe what we have
provided is something that is extremely
important you now have a documented
clinical supervision of rural health
workers every event is documented their
decision is documented the findings they
put in the treatment they put in the
follow-up to their treatment is all
documented electronically now in a very
user friendly fashion and so now you do
have for the first time physicians can
look at these people and statistically
find out in varies
reporting systems do they need more
training are they treating the diseases
other diseases being treated properly is
there a resistance occurring and all of
that on data that right now is not
captured if it is it's written down but
it's not able to be done on the fly and
it provides a standard of care the
monitoring and evaluation piece is very
interesting because even on the mobile
phone one of the really again I keep
talking about one app is that we're able
to customize just our ability to monitor
and evaluate and it can be done on the
fly with the forms and immediately up up
uploaded into the phone just very simple
so you can do a monitoring and
evaluation one of the cool things is
let's say you're in a village in this
particular organization perhaps like an
organization like World Vision wants to
know something as simple as is there
electricity you can add that to the form
and gather that data and immediately get
other information and then it comes in
and next opinion knowledge management
can run stats obviously that data is an
important in Diagnostics necessarily but
it does allow us to do some monitoring
and evaluation we can monitor and
evaluate not only follow up with
medications but pregnancies you can
through for example the one app when a
child is born you can send out a note
that says to the health worker see if
the child is able to nurse is the child
drinking water you can ask these
questions and if all the answers are
hitting the standard that is appropriate
you got a green light and it just shows
up green keep doing what you're doing it
shows up yellow then what happens is
immediately an alert is sent to the next
higher level supervisor that says we
need intervention in this area or we
need an immunization or whatever it is
all of that is programmable very easily
on this system one of the things that we
found very early on is the diagnosis
accuracy not only in u.s. medicine
there's various studies that say there's
seven to twenty percent misdiagnosis
but in the in the rural medicine is
people make diagnosis based upon their
level of knowledge and so they bail out
and make a diagnosis and it's considered
a diagnosis and all of our public health
systems count that as the diagnosis what
we've done is we said we need to be more
granular we need to go down to the
finding we need to gather the findings
because the grouping of findings may
validate a diagnosis or it may validate
that this is not a diagnosis this is not
the appropriate diagnosis because they
didn't have enough information to make
that diagnosis so now I think that we we
can do better early outbreak we can
tolerate misdiagnosis we can look at
various reporting functions because
technology is now allowed us to get so
granular and run these reports one of
the things using the architecture that
we we have as it provides a common
medical data architecture it doesn't
matter how the data is stored it allows
us to be able to pull it in interpret it
and dump it back into your system very
important from that standpoint it allows
the whole broad data accessibility
whether you want to pick it up on a
phone whether that person goes through
multiple levels of treatment their
records are still available on every
event in which they were seen and can be
reported back we also believe in a
transparency of data analysis our job is
to be able to get data in our job is to
share that data in the public health
system to allow other people to be able
to go in and figure out what solutions
exist and so we are very much in the the
public health data is so important to be
available to all and be transparent the
regionalization of next depending was
one of the greatest challenges that we
had and so I think that what we we
looked at is we took global and regional
and what I refer to it as is what I call
a fallback system India for example has
some diseases that we can overall say
these diseases exist or sub-sahara
Africa but then India may be broken down
into regions that have winters or
mountains with winters mountains without
winters coastal and
claims so as we gather data and as we
learn we can go more granular on our on
our our prevalence and sensitivities but
it always falls back to what we know so
that data is not yet there it goes back
to what is known and then as we learn we
can add the data in and so it uses that
ability to regionalize what that means
is for example the creative group at UPG
we can do a data collection in a new
region in a matter of hours takes hours
to be able to take it into another area
to be able to do the diagnostics and
reports is a matter of just days to be
able to convert it regionally now to do
the full diagnostic in the specialty
language takes a lot longer but we have
the ability to say that this finding
shows up in this fashion and you can put
it into a different language the
database doesn't care the language it
cares did that finding it filled into
that field so it's very interesting and
if you use voice directed technology not
voice recognition you can ask questions
and a native tongue in a very fast
method using next opinions clinical
decision support system one of the other
challenges that you have in global
medicine is published that everybody
wants to own their data and nobody wants
to share with anyone else not only do
countries do that but organizations do
that and sometimes even within
organizations they won't share from one
department to the other so one of the
things that we decided to do is to
create what's called publish set you can
go into our database and create a subset
of data that says for this organization
for this location this is the data that
is published in as your database we keep
a mirror de-identified image they can
own that data they can use it for
financial support they can do whatever
they want with it we with the mirror
data can run all of the statistics all
of the public health information and can
pinpoint it back to an individual
they can connect it to the individual so
by creating this we've allowed people to
say we don't want your data we don't
want to make the money off of the
database we want a global database that
is what is necessary to really do public
health so they own it they control the
data we manage the indata in a
de-identified as i talked about before
regionalization as a user skill level
and it has a structure of being able to
fall back let's talk about next opinion
as a platform I've given you a little of
technology lets start moving into what
do you do with this so as a platform we
look at four different areas there's yes
it what's the suit that that's exactly
where we're going exactly because that
is a huge challenge scalability and
that's exactly where we're going what
event I mean you mentioned briefly that
if someone's blinking imaging data that
can prove a whole sort of a space right
are usually just the x-rays you looking
at just be going to take visual example
yourself on camera or being able to do
understand yeah there's again based upon
the interface the end and the the level
of the the programming you cell phone or
pc for example if you're looking at a
cell phone and you have a x-ray finding
you'll only have the results showing if
you go into our H is system you're going
to see the x-ray come up and you're
going to see what that looks like so it
goes through and the other you're
absolutely right with the cell phone you
frequently can take a picture get that
data there are some some areas where
they're beginning to look at automatic
Diagnostics through the imaging but it
can always go back to the pc the ph c or
higher and get it and put it back in so
you're able to transmit and the one app
is really cool that's one of the things
we liked as we we added imaging to that
piece that they had not at UPG
previously I mean picture imaging for
that very reason dermatol
logical is a great way to do that in
rural areas so and I'll show you for
example in our H is system you hover
over a finding and it will pull up an
x-ray right in front of you or whatever
imaging you need but scalability is a
huge issue do we have an answer to all
the problems answer's no and one of them
is has to do with why I'm here why I'm
interested to be here is there's still
problems to be solved and that needs to
be solved by some people brighter than I
am in those areas and so what we're
looking at is saying this is our domain
knowledge but there are other domain
knowledge that have to build in this if
we are going to change world medicine so
we aren't the solution we are part of a
solution so like you said here we've got
a whole data collection system that you
have to talk about data interpretation
data storage and data reporting here's
the platform that we have built I want
you to think of this you've got this
global databases of all the aggregated
data you've got a personal health record
which whoever wants to own the EHR the
platform that says the diagnostic engine
event engine and search engine that's
what we do the diagnostic engine I'm
going to help to diagnose a disease an
event engine is I'm going to take such
things as follow-ups i'm going to ask
for alerts i'm going to ask for various
events and the search engine has the
ability to be able to go in and get the
data all the way down into a granular
basis out of that we have the monitoring
and evaluation messaging engine UPG for
example with the one app is a messaging
engine that's using that there may be an
SMS methodology that may come out of
there they may be various aspects to
come in we look at ourselves as a
platform we say other people build you
can build some interfaces on us we've
got this piece put together that is a
huge effort and how it's built and how
it works in monitoring and evaluation is
another area we're weekend we need lots
of people to be involved in that
epidemiological studies so I think the
whole ability to dump into this system
and to use the system just to come back
out there are some aspects
it's almost like everything in case for
publishing API stores absolutely be for
you absolutely business as well as a
technical problem essentially your open
source I'm talking you're absolutely
right now it's very interesting because
what's what's fascinating is like I said
we have a 501c3 never have a business
model and essentially what we're saying
is you know we're not going to give away
our code to our engine but we are really
building on the open-source concept
we're really building on saying you know
this is what we want to do and we're
going to do this we're going to give you
a lot of API is to be able to come in we
have to do that this you know it's
that's why we kind of used openmrs is
our first mapping our NX km database is
actually can do more and as got a lot of
better things but you know what it makes
a proprietary but if you got open in our
ass you can come in and do that sort of
stuff and get to us so you know we
really are looking at that aspect so
you're absolutely right that we felt
again when when Eric described my
mission my mission is not to build a
proprietary database diagnostic system
it's to build a platform that other
people can use because unless we all
work together unless it is open to
people who are brighter than i am and
our company is in other areas the
ultimate solution is saving lives and
that's the only way you can do it not
yet we are at that point but your
absolute that's our next we are closed
december maybe that's where we're at
right now this is just the Kodiaks this
is the the one app application which is
out of the UPG and it's just you know
various ways of there's two elements to
what we built with you p g one is called
a health manager which is accessible by
consumers to be able to go in on a
cellular platform to be able to get
regionalized diagnostic data health tips
all of that without using the term we're
kind of the u.p geez webmd of developing
countries so that's like a november
release and
and we'll be looking in South Africa and
India and that's our role we've got 15
countries or so that we're geared
towards and that's the consumer base
we're running all the back end yes and
so when you when you go to one app
you'll see whatever the name is but
Robertson health manager or next opinion
health manager etc and in the back end
we're doing all the health tips that are
regionalized we're doing the Diagnostics
etc storing the data the other part of
that is data collection which we look at
with a lot of humanitarian efforts
gathering data at the HTW louder level
pulling data and using the cell phone
and and so those two components who are
both ready to come out of in November
carry books what was that cute carriers
Toco Toco I'm not enjoy guys oh yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah you know like I
think Microsoft has relationships with
blue level tell blue label telecom and
oxygen in India we also are going to be
looking at independently we can work
with companies such as Tata India and
all of those things from a distribution
standpoint so company based corporate
based as well as we've got distributors
we've got some meetings on humanitarian
groups to release and use it also sorry
this is the Microsoft one app just kind
of a this is a mid-level phone and just
kind of the way that it might work out
where you just can kind of go in and
click a few buttons and put a few things
in and the data comes in one of the
things that we thought was kind of an
interesting challenges in dealing with
rural India for example names you know
are rather interesting because you have
some very difficult names to put in on a
cell phone one of the simple solutions
is you take a paper write your name on
hold it up snap a picture and a person
that's on a keyboard can enter the data
in you've already got a unique
identifier with it so there's many
different ways that you can find some
practical solutions to be able to get
some of the problems
government what their population count
is
so how do you make sure that everybody
has uniquely identified what we have
been able to do with our next opinion is
to have an identifier that is associated
if it is a particular Asha or health
worker that has a phone that phone is
connected to a region into a village and
so what you have is a beginning of a
numerical solution to this is the
village this is the state this is the
region that numerical which they don't
have to enter because it's automatically
done and then when you create the record
you have an additional unique identifier
that unique identifier can be mapped to
a national ID or anything because they
don't have it we create it and will map
it to however they want to do it so that
we have had to create the unique
identifiers that can be mapped you're
absolutely right yeah and we do work
with the government's as far as seeing
if what's there do they have a plan or
what is the plan etc this is an example
of data gathering now this is just the
pilot study don't think of this is the
user interface but this is kind of how
next opinion works on the left side is
where you have patient data on the right
side of general reference so that means
anytime I go in and do a search where
next opinion is very different than your
typical WebMD Mayo Clinic searches is if
I am on the right left side and i am a
52 year old male with a history of
diabetes etc and i go search the
database you won't find me able to get
diseases that are only common to females
you won't find me finding diseases that
are unique to pediatrics it filters your
findings based upon what is existent in
your health record on the right side is
generic I can go in and find out
anything so that's part of the search
process you have some various ways of
getting in epidemiology then what we
have on even at the phc is you have
what's called quick picks on the right
hand side here you'll see at the bottom
you have all the different diseases and
it's either do I have it or does my
family have it
and it has a smart search but on the top
are quick picks quick picks are what are
most likely to exist in your area the
most common diseases and it's a user
usability interface so that what comes
up is it's very much they can stay up in
that top area most of the time click it
in and it's very much of a user and that
usability issue and that is part of our
regionalization you can go through and
all of the findings whether their
symptoms whether there's labs whether
they're imaging and all of their eyes
things you not only have a description
but you have a link that they may have
with other diseases and our findings now
data interpretation I'm going to just
show you a couple of screenshots of how
next opinion works and again this is the
research tool not the user interface on
the phone it works different etc here as
a series of symptoms were entered and at
the bottom you'll see that there are 11
pieces of information and evidence in
those 11 pieces you know being male or
female age are pieces of evidence and
various aspects former history whether
you take whether you've had a
immunization or not is in evidence but
all of a sudden we run in some findings
through a chief complaint and we have
whoops I slip skip to slide goodnight no
oh we have a Miss slide what you'll see
here though is I've got malaria and I
have a confidence level now with the end
user level 1 and 2 that's a dot green
yellow or red we don't give them the
number with a more sophisticated user we
may give the number so that it comes
this way a green disease says the group
of physicians feel at your level you're
qualified to treat with the finding or
the treatment that's here for disease to
reach green it has to be you're
qualified to treat we're confident you
have it then you get a green if you're
qualified to treat we're not confident
you have it you have a yellow which says
you need more information over here on
the right
is one of the different information
those are suggestions that help us
differentiate your disease if it is a
yellow disease meaning you aren't
qualified to treat at your level but we
are confident then you have a different
statement it's likely you have this but
you need to refer the person a red
disease says there's no way get them in
for help immediately so we're able to
use green yellow red not only on
Diagnostics but on alerts on follow ups
on all of those various things yes
yellow is I'm not qualified but i'm
confident i have it or I'm it's you're
not qualified and I don't know if you
have it or you are qualified but I don't
know that you haven't both of those
would be yellows both would have a
different statement there is a
qualifying statement that says you know
you probably have this disease but you
aren't qualified you need to have
somebody treat it that's a good
telemedicine call type of disease this
going back to your imaging is a
dashboard that we created that
integrates with any H is system now
we've created a clinical dashboard in
which to put in perspective our phrase
that we use is doctors should be
information interpreters not information
gatherers you need the data when you
want it where you want it and how you
want it so we have a dashboard where
basically using this engine if you are
an infectious disease doctor there will
be a template that comes out and says
most infectious disease doctors would
like to know platelet counts I mean WBC
counts temperature charts and whatever
it is this is what you want next opinion
when you go in and pull up that your
patient it will show you your graphs of
temperature it'll show you the
medications it'll show you any alerts of
anything this is a chest x-ray and if
you hover over it shows the chest x-ray
you don't have to go get it it shows up
what's most important is let's say you
prescribe a gentamicin for example for
an infection and we know that it has a
high side effect of renal disease next
opinion in a suggestion will say you
might want to run a creatinine RB
that so this is something that will be
ready in January but it goes back to
that core technology at different use
this is kind of a Ferrari where the one
app is a weed whacker although it's a
pretty powerful weed whacker so again
using it from that standpoint you'll
also notice that in the the corner or on
the right hand side and these are
widgets so you can move them around
wherever you want them you're going to
see next opinion setting there with the
probability of the disease what we feel
is it needs to be sitting in the
background this is mostly a hospital
information system this is that HD a
secondary hospital or things of that
nature is it should be running in the
background it shouldn't be interfering
but if all of a sudden you look and you
say I've only got at eighty percent
diagnosis I'm ready to go you can go
over there that'll say here's some ways
to get you up to ninety percent it'll
also be able to go you could say I want
to run a cat scan or an MRI and it will
give you which one is you know most
likely to add to the diagnosis and in
our version two it not only will today
in that hospital how long will it take
you to get a cat scan run and an MRI but
what are the different costs affects the
different effects of that cost so you
might be able to get something done in
two days less expensive and it adds
almost amount of Diagnostics to it so it
has a little bit of a workflow to it
that will be ready in june of next year
next opinion is a product you know i
really look at next opinion one is a
plug into h is systems once again to
steal a phrase from another company BASF
we don't do anything ourselves we make
other people better that's kind of what
we see ourselves and you know we look at
for example there may be an amalgam is
system and say you know we can make you
better there may be another system out
there we make you better because what we
say is this is our particular strength
this is what we do and we want to stay
within that realm but we want others to
work with us we especially have spent a
significant amount of time into the
rural and remote healthcare our passion
is to take technology
which is essential to take quality
medicine into the rural area and by
using next opinion you have clinical
supervision you have standard of care
you have diagnosis in the area of the
non-physician yet you have the
supervision of that you have a treatment
standard you have follow-up you know
it's done and you've got monitoring and
evaluation and the ability to provide
alerts many of the challenges that we've
had my next slide is going to talk about
the challenges we haven't met but at
this particular point it allows us to do
telemedicine yes sir gigantic thing that
everybody feeds aqui no no lots of
instances we're going to business
relationship we are in the process you
know you ask the question are we running
one instance and the answer is in each
of these pilot areas the answer is yes
the technology that we're doing now is
moving that out of that so that'll be I
think October is coming out of that
system we again philosophically I
believe the cloud is the answer there
are some hesitancy ease with various
organizations groups etc so that case
you run instances on their local server
and then put it back into the cloud
unidentified data so our business model
that's what we look at that's also what
we look to Microsoft to say okay we've
done this help us with this problem that
is a problem that we come and say we
need you to answer that you know one of
the reasons why I'm really pleased to be
here is there are problems that are
above our skills that's one of them what
is the infrastructure to support this
real time and I think it's a great
question so when we're ready to roll
right now we have to do it as we can at
this particular point but if we're going
to do a really worldwide global database
where does health fault fit where does
amalga fit with it you know and I'm
going to go into that where do we go
with the infrastructure just by sister
capsule absolutely as a non-profit it
depends on who it is you know for
example an area in which we have gained
a tremendous amount of demand of small
hospitals in the US for an H is system
because they can't afford them and it's
very affordable that comes through our
profit system India hospitals are very
much liking us because we have a
regionalized clinical decision support
that's out of the profit on the other
hand if you know sometimes even a
government contract can be profit
depending but if you're sitting there in
a specially sub-sahara Africa or in
areas whether just you know certain
states in India chattisgarh there's no
money so then we run it through our
nonprofit but it is our ability for us
to be sustainable to say non profit
profit various things of that nature I
believe strongly that we the next
movement I personally would like to see
that because I have a relationship
pretty heavily for years with Microsoft
to take something such as health fault
and make an interactive personal health
record the technology exists Google's
playing with it with predictive they got
one guy running around doing some stuff
we are so far beyond that if we are
ready at this particular point for
medicine to go to interactive personal
health records that is an
extraordinarily I believe important
aspect also case management resource
utilization we've been contacted by
insurance companies that are saying can
you keep health care costs down well
obviously if you can pinpoint a specific
test to be run to help you differentiate
versus a battery of tests that helps
various ways of dealing with that here
you go scaling big problem this comes
from a brook book that Kristin told
David hacker Mendell DeHart a chapter
that Kristen toll david hackman dell
dehart myself wrote and it's called how
do you scale health care how do you take
this in scale well I'm going to give
this to this phraseology to Kristen
because Kristen created this we call it
scale up
how do you take medical databases that
are hundreds of thousands and turn it
into millions problem number one I don't
have a solution necessarily I think you
guys do problem number two is scale out
how do you regionalize to multiple
countries and regions with language
regulations organizations we have a good
solution there scale across multiple
diseases and programs how do you
coordinate HIV you know diarrheal
diseases maternal care with the Gates
Foundation etc we've got the technology
it's a matter of those joint
cooperations to put those programs in
scale in one of the things that I think
is extremely important about what we do
is being able to get down to a granular
level I tell you having a great deal of
experience in rural health if you can't
scale in and you can't get down to that
patient finding you're just making
decisions on inaccurate data without any
validity we need to validate the data
we're making decisions on so when I look
at that I say one of the major problems
that we see is this is scaling up
scaling up it's an infrastructure system
that's far beyond our small company it's
an infrastructure that I think ties in
several companies and several solutions
and that is one of the challenges we can
run this and we can run it to a point
and then we will stall without that
scaling up what I have here is what i
call a global database and some touch
points and where we look at Microsoft
for example and we look at other
partners and say where what can we do
and where do we need help you have this
user and then you do have a method of
data collection one app for example is a
great data collection system I think one
app is fantastic i love the way it goes
it's limited from an SMS text standpoint
that means certain areas of the world
can't use one app so the question is
where does that technology
come from that's going to be necessary I
can argue I can argue the one app
platform as being a superior platform
for data collection but if you don't
have the infrastructure to use that
mobile phone system you can argue all
day that it's superior but if it doesn't
have the ability to work in that system
then you need another solution so
there's an area where we need a solution
by using the API system that we have
many people can use data data collection
systems in through our system so we say
you know we've created a foundation
let's get other people to be able to do
that we can build for them on one app we
can build for them etc but there are
other people that need to be able to
look at that data storage I tell you
this is a nightmare for me it's an
absolute nightmare from the standpoint
of we can gather data we can store data
we have to deal with the regulatory and
most important we have to deal with the
global aspect of this has anyone ever
tried a database system that could
potentially be this large and manage it
so I take that one and I say you know
what I can brainstorm with you I have no
solutions because you are far over my
head on that one I do not know how to do
that and that is our rate limiting step
at this particular point data
interpretation you know I look at amalga
and I'm intrigued by that technology for
example and I think of what we do and
then with that the amalga system that
there's some some ability to be doing
even greater data interpretation
especially because they have similar
languages probably because we have a
couple of guys that are pretty heavy in
that area data feedback I think not only
gathering data but going back and
reporting data back and being able to
use that whether it's through the mobile
one app platform or whether it's through
a health fault system we are in a
position that I want what what our fall
releases is I want to give you a new
term it's called push medicine we
believe in what's called push medicine
pull medicine as pull medicine is what p
do now they go to the internet and they
say I have diabetes I want to find out
about diabetes or they go and they say
my doctor said I have this I want to
find out about it push medicine says if
i take the database that next opinion
has plus one of our company's called
robertson wellness which is another
technology that we do i can go in and
say because you're diabetic obese and
mail here's a new piece of information
you need to read I can push it to them I
can push information to them only
relevant information to them to me that
is a whole new way of doing medicine
pull Madison means i have to have
something that asks me to go dig it out
whether it's all of a sudden i got a lab
test back I may be months late push
medicine says i'm going to give you new
information pay attention to it here's a
new way of doing it here's new research
here's a something that we know about
your medication is a whole new way of
doing it next opinion can do that but it
needs the data feedback system one app
we will be doing that data learning
again i kind of look at the amalga
system and saying ooh I salivate with
taking the data that we have our data
learning but amalgams data learning for
example or some system like that can
really help us change medicine and again
the analytics that are provided from
amalga you keep seeing hearing me say
amalga i think it's the future there
it's a semantic database we're a
semantic database so there's a lot of
fascinating things that I find so when I
kind of look at this in conclusion and
then I'll kind of open it up for a
little discussion you know we don't have
all of the answers we have done a lion
share of and met some of the solutions
and some of the challenges in dealing
with global medicine we now are in a
position of saying the solution needs to
deal with some very very important
infrastructure issues with being able to
work with other people who do things
specifically better but it is
fascinating because from my perspective
and it's been with the help of Microsoft
for the first time you know you take
Eric how long have you been dealing with
bays I mean this is work so 25 years I
mean you take you take you take guys
like Eric and you take guys like david
that have just been digging into it and
it's kind of neat that you know I feel
that we're very fortunate to be able to
take those pioneers and take their stuff
and put it into a system that offers a
solution but we are only a piece to the
puzzle and I think one of the things
you'll find about our attitude is we
need help we are not the solution we are
a piece to the puzzle and from that it's
it's very interesting that we look at
and say this is what we're not my father
was very wise when he said to me know
what you're good at and do it and then
find people who are better at things and
ask them to do it we need help in
epidemiology we need help in metrics we
need help an infrastructure we need help
in analytics we can't be everything and
for that we need to have good solid
partners with research valid information
any questions all right so I'm going to
tend to catch up with the date on the
qualitative days
cwp everything began I step to take
for set up
since you're covered in total population
some sort of qualitative or quantitative
evaluation
whether it be an actual set of runs with
patience for your proxy database coming
in from
with some reporting model in India
New York City and see how well I was
does she work and I'll get ice slide 17
to heaven year infinity we have three
studies that I did not put in because I
didn't want to I you know again trying
to get vision trying to get technology
etc first study that we did had to do
with 300 patients in which we were
looking at did we make general
practitioners better and were we
accurate so that was the basis of that
first study the second study was what
level of skill and this was a Gates
Foundation funded study was what are the
skill levels of the people who can even
be involved in clinical decision support
and who can be involved in data
collection and we were we were somewhat
surprised that that is a major hurdle
that some of the people that are the
front line workers don't read either
they can't write their own language and
so therefore have a difficult time so
voice directed helps if you can ask a
question in their native language and
they can answer yes or no but that was a
challenge we have a partial solution the
third thing was to take two thousand
multi purpose health workers and look at
two things one is the collection skills
of their present system versus does next
opinion get what I refer to as valid
data because I am a stickler that says
when you make conclusions on data that's
that's subjective is is a difficulty so
we looked at that and just to two pieces
of data collection capabilities and the
other thing is how did they rate with
those 2,000 patients compared to the
physician in that study has not yet been
published but it's complete correct
that's been complete those were done
using an assignment stitute of medical
sciences as our supervising we went
through all of the the standards that
are appropriate for india medical
services and medical society and all the
protocols so that it could be quote
unquote a publishable article and and so
from that standpoint we used all of
those criteria and all three
but there's a lot more so I'm a just
continuous continuous they have not
published it yet we finished it in
december i have not seen it published
it's something that's available we can
give you a a summary of it i believe
without getting in trouble
okay because we were we were somewhat
surprised when we first you know of
course microsoft owns oh i don't know if
they own totally but have a relationship
with tell me and tell me being voice
recognition and we said you know that's
not a that's that's a great application
perhaps with with health fault
interactive personal health records
which is phenomenal but voice directed
using our rules based what's really cool
is using our rules based template to get
predictors in you can ask questions you
can you can you can set it up where
somebody just has to ask the question
you answer yes or no before bass kicks
in once bass kicks in you have a series
of questions that can be asked and
answered so it's it's a really adaptable
way of being able to get to those people
who are illiterate yeah I've heard about
that and and you know okay but see this
is this is where you know our philosophy
of courses and this is what we do but
there's so many solutions that can build
on us and for us to try to find all of
those those things as ridiculous we're
just again kind of in the attitude of
saying we're really we really think we
have something cool here it's it's been
tested enough it's got some solid theory
and testing and and now it just meet
needs to be made better by partners an
opportunity to dance
discussion and interaction a lot of
mobile health solutions for around the
world
I was just invited to September 15th to
a meeting in India by Intel just today
and yeah and similar with the the India
public health system and so that i will
see if i can get there because that it
is a matter of cooperation we were
taught
newsies kind of things and you develop
some plugs by analytics for once users
so even some of the district
validated tools validated data and start
doing some studies on their own
culture because we play statistical
models and you know
I think there's another thing too I know
you guys at Microsoft Research had a
maternal care database or yeah I mean
those are the types of things that we
say you know if we get to the point
where where people think what we do is
legitimate we needed we need data and
and you know grabbing that data putting
that in and a format that of you use
those are very important things that we
look at from from that standpoint would
facilitate your skiing a technical point
is a wave of sustainable things right so
people have to stop me on there are some
money being made the Four Weddings and
services there's an incentive just keep
it up tonight you know yeah you know
that the practicality of it is is it has
to be sustainable and it has to be
something that people work with blue
label telecom which was one of your
ventures I talked with one of the guys
last week some really creative ideas of
how to use a micro business with this
process we've we have some strong
corporate relationships in India that
provides some of those things so I think
there's a whole whole strategy like you
like you say a you know not only data
collection but business management
maintaining a business model
infrastructure model there's just so
much that needs to wrap around it you're
fortunate that you're the first people
that have you know heard our vision well
not the first people that hear our
version but the first group from the
standpoint of us saying this is where
we're at now in our deployment and here
are some of our problems and I can't
think of a better place to throw our
problems than at microsoft research and
see if you have any solutions
great thank you